tensions are rising in the Middle East
between Iran and the United States the
trouble administration authorized
military strikes in response to a rocket
attack from an Iranian backed Araki
militia that killed an American
contractor the US military called the
action precision defensive strikes the
iranian-backed militias says at least 25
fighters were killed and are vowing
revenge against American aggression
correspondent Kevin cork is following
the president in West Palm Beach Florida
good evening Kevin evening Mike your
right leaders for that iranian-backed
militias say the death toll is rising
you mentioned 25 and they're vowing
revenge against the quote American
Ravens this was a defensive action
designed to protect American forces and
American citizens in Iraq and it was
aimed also at deterring Iran the silence
of the strikes recordings malai their
power and precision but their message to
Tehran was certainly loud and clear in
all five targets in Iraq and Syria were
hit by the u.s. on Sunday target's
controlled by an Iran back militia a
measure of revenge said US officials for
the death of an American contractor who
was killed in a rocket attack last week
this administration made a fundamental
chip from where President Obama and his
team work we took a very different
direction we put enormous pressure to
deny resources to Hezbollah to try and
deny resources to Shia militias like the
ones that came after Americans an Iraqi
facility in Iraq yesterday where there
were Americans working to work in to
counter Isis the strikes hit three
locations in Iraq to others in Syria and
while a US response to an attack that
kills Americans is not uncommon Sunday's
retaliation targeting Iranian proxies
has renewed concerns of a possible exit
of hostilities one that could lead to a
proxy war with Iran or worse no no we
are warning the United States as we
warned before that their illegal
presence means they are standing against
the Iraqi people and the Iraqi people
have the right to confront them with all
types of resistance a resistance that
seen the Iranians lean more heavily on
China and Russia both of whom recently
conducted naval exercises with Tehran
but continues to insist that the US
presence in the Gulf creates
security in the region still its
relationship with Iran presents a unique
challenge for the Kremlin and its
relationship with the United States
because while Tehran remains a reliable
strategic partner and bulwark against
American interests in the region
it's undeniable link to terrorism is
something Moscow ironically partners
with the u.s. to fight a crucial
cooperative that President Putin noted
over the weekend thanking President
Trump in a phone call for US assistance
in preventing a terror attack on Russian
interests Vladimir Putin also talked to
President Trump by telephone over the
weekend and once again Mikey invited him
to take part in the Victory Day
celebrations coming up in Russia on May
the 9th of course that is to mark the
Soviet Union's victory over Nazi Germany
in World War two the president
previously saying that he's open to the
invitation but he has not said whether
or not he'll actually take him up on it
Mike Kevin cork thanks very much